welcome back to the morning toast we are
so excited to be sitting down with
austin kroll from southern charm winter
house and a little bit of summer house
you've made a small appearance huge
impact small but mighty hi austin
hello ladies so good to see you
so good to see you thank you so much for
joining us here in new york you're here
for what the bravo up fronts we i was we
were here for bravo upfront yeah which i
didn't know what that meant do y'all
know what that means yeah we used to
used to work in the b2b world so we are
familiar with upfront but i also feel
like as a bravo star if you get invited
to the up runs to like be part of the
the front-facing people like that's a
big sign it's an honor it's an honor
because not everyone gets to go so that
is something that i was thinking about
too uh something that late night i was
with
sandoval we like would end up out like
outside of the hotel just chatting about
everything you know he's a chatter and
like that
thought he was like bro
we're here they asked for us to be here
we're special okay you know and so with
everything going on i was like yeah
they asked me to be here yeah that's a
good time
who else was there who else is good for
their next season from charm it it was
me and shep i think that craig was
supposed to be there as well but craig
had his one year anniversary of his
store on king street oh saturday we're
sitting on sewing down south pillows
these are sds pillows they're fabulous
yeah it's really good there's nothing
wrong with yourself your pillows if if
you're listening they're really nice a
lot of support so you were
the topic of conversation on many
reality shows recently most notably
summer house which is crazy because you
were on like two episodes total
um
i was there for 48 hours
and the whole season is about you yeah
and i look i didn't watch any of it but
of course i have people that do and they
tell me about it and then you see some
backlash about it and
i i was shocked
at the repercussions or just how much
that i was on it right and like chose to
use me and like take other main cast
members that were very much there yeah
right and make it seem like they weren't
there yes so i guess that i just didn't
know
because my f so my first day there
i was very tame right and like intend i
was like austin keep it together mm-hmm
because i was supposed to go when craig
went the first weekend right
we learned this at the reunion a little
bit okay and then yes girl carl to you
not to go because it would be thirsty to
be on three shows no that's not true i i
wish that he would have because i
because i was looking for any sign to
not to go
because when craig first went you know
it it was like we had been on winter
house and so they wanted like you know
the austin craig package to go you know
him and paige were like just beginning
to talk right it wasn't like a
full-blown thing he was you know excited
to go and see her
and so i was like i don't know man i'm
just like my headspace is not right i'm
really not feeling it i really don't if
i want to be on camera right now so i
didn't go
and then lindsay you know we're talking
talking talking as
i mean we should talk all the freaking
time and she was like it's my birthday
come we're gonna have a blast
and i got to thinking i was like well
you know it's lindsey's birthday
i'm going to be able to go
and like have fun in the hamptons right
does that sound like fun
with your friends no normally that
sounds fun yeah
and she texted me the other day after
part one of the reunion and she was like
remember when i called you and told you
it was gonna be so much fun for you to
come to the hamptons she goes i'm so
sorry that all this nonsense is
happening to you and i was like oh my
gosh lindsay it's never ending yeah and
uh and she was like
that seems like you know a year and a
half ago because it was a year and a
half ago did they ask you to go to the
reunion
no no so you haven't really had a chance
a lot has been spoken about you you
haven't really spoken on it you have
been you know
dragged quite a bit for how you handled
sierra how you handled lindsay in just
like that 48 hour time
in the house so i guess my question for
you is what do you feel like wasn't said
like what do you feel like people are
misunderstanding about you because i
think you feel like you've been kind of
s like sidelined trash
it's emotional it's emotional it's
emotional it's clear in my throat just
to make sure that that this is well
heard it's just
um
you know going to a show that you're not
a cast member of
you don't you don't get the green screen
you don't get to show up the weekend
after
and like apologize
you know you don't get to cut like you
don't get your you know redemption so to
speak yeah and and especially couldn't
go to the reunion
and um
yeah i mean you're right i i haven't
said much about the topic because
summerhouse was like such a trigger word
for me and and like i hate to say it and
like admit it but it was just like no
well the thing that you don't know is
what is the thing like i
you know am now very like you know what
like we are moving onwards and upwards
but
you know just like having your narrative
said for you is very frustrating
right it's very frustrating and um
and
i i
guess that that what it is in a in a
nutshell is that
um so it was last summer i was like five
to six months like officially you know
single i had moved on you know from
something that that wasn't the greatest
and i was like i am having fun and i'm
single and i'm allowed to do
you know this and that and i you know
was i like selfish in my like you know
hot boy summer right quote unquote
um you know yes uh and and and i
realized that in hindsight i realized
that you know very soon thereafter
um there was like an apology you know
where like i was able to speak to
everyone it just wasn't you know used
which is who did you apologize to um
sierra got it okay i was able to you
know pull her aside and have a combo and
you know and and and really talk to her
about
um i understand like i didn't
i guess that i didn't realize that her
and lindsey were like
at odds they just don't have a good
relationship and then to see
you with her must have drawn drove sarah
crazy
yes yeah well so you know lindsay never
really told me that her and sierra
weren't you know that tight right
because you know lindsay isn't isn't
like that you know she's not like you
know f that person or whatever right you
know she was just like so when i when i
came
yeah uh sierra was like okay well you're
not gonna be in her bed and i was like i
wasn't planning on it right i totally
wasn't planning on i think that i'm
gonna like you know sleep in andrea's
bed or something um so like
i guess that i just didn't know and then
on lindsay's birthday
you know all all hell broke loose
because i just decided to drink a bunch
of tequila
and we were sitting in lindsay's room
prior to you know the party and we were
just talking to each other and i was
like and she was like [ __ ] everything
right let's just have fun and i was like
yes i'd love that mentality and this was
before winter house had aired two so i
didn't get to see like like what the
reactions were from like me and sierra
or me and lindsay maybe
and so i was flying blind from like what
had
happened or what was going to be shown
on winterhouse
so
then it's just like
you know
like it just kept on snowballing yeah do
you feel like you make decisions on the
show on any of the shows that you're on
based on how people react on social
media like does it inform your decision
making at all
no and i'm gonna say no in the sense
no and yes so like you know yes in in
the sense that
when when you see yourself get like you
know worked up
on someone
right and then and then you watch it and
and and maybe see like a social media
like oh my you know then you sit back
and you're like austin
keep it together like if someone's
yelling like let let you know them yell
as much as you possibly can before you
so like i try to keep my emotions in
check more
right after like having seen some things
where i've been you know like emotional
or whatever because it's not an
attractive quality to watch you know
anyone you know yelling and huffing and
puffing no it must be really positive
but to be able to learn from yourself
like most people can't see themselves
and they don't ever get the perspective
of you know being outside of the moment
and getting to watch their reaction so
that's like a good thing but as long as
it's not informing like how you live
your life based on like what people are
gonna no no no no i i mean look i i
i couldn't if if i tried
to be
you know different like i'm not going to
show up one day and be like a buttoned
up like you know james bond right okay
now i've changed yeah
yeah this is not going to happen well i
think like the major takeaway from the
summer house reunion between sierra and
lindsay was like you know
it's austin's fault pretty much like it
was you know and you really never got to
speak for yourself no i i'm i'm so i
didn't watch the reunion
i i was certainly shocked to like hear a
bunch of things right a bunch of people
just like you know hurling my name
around and i'm like oh this is
interesting yeah but there's also like a
lot of things that you like said or
maybe influence that had nothing to do
with the lindsay sierra stuff you know
more to do with like kristen and craig
and paige and when you told lindsay that
information and when she told it to pay
oh right okay interesting i forgot about
that oh my gosh
yeah how much more we used on this
season um yeah so
you know this is one of those things too
where craig
craig says
and he's been telling everyone that like
you know we didn't talk for three months
because of x y and z and i'm like that's
just not true you know craig and i were
still podcasting you know it was just
kind of walking on eggshells it like
said that we weren't talking right
and um
craig
thinks or or thought craig thought that
like i was like maliciously trying to
like tell lindsay some information which
i don't know if it was
then
when when like she was driving in the
hamptons or not but you know to me it it
it doesn't matter the way that craig
said it to me was that i said to lindsay
like hey if like if you want to [ __ ]
with craig right you know
you know here's some info and i was like
craig i would never do that like that is
how it came off i was like you're single
and i want you to flourish pal i really
do it's just that a friend called me and
was like hey is it you or is it him
right and i was like it's not me we all
thought it was you you want to know
because by the way
like at dinners and things like i like i
would like sit next to her on purpose to
like throw everyone off and you guys
were all friends and then i was getting
the like you know brunt of it and i'm
like and then that's when i realized
that i was like being like a bravo level
famous is fun being like a higher level
stressful is all yeah like when all that
was happening i was like oh my gosh like
didn't didn't realize that your level of
fame was like right up here
yeah so do you really feel like a lot of
the negative sentiments about you are
due partly to your own actions which
you've taken responsibility for but also
because you really just weren't given a
platform to make it right like you
weren't giving confessionals you weren't
given an opportunity at the reunion and
you think if you were like
people would have seen your side a
little bit more and i think people might
have had an easier time moving on
because it's a story it evolves and now
we're talking about next weekend sure
sure so so certainly not like absolved
right uh it's not like oh man if i would
have been on there but
like it i just like i had you know
remorse for it and i had like look i'm
just trying to learn and grow and like
i'm going to learn and grow from this
but i never had the opportunity to say
it
and um you know that's all that people
kind of want to see is like taking
accountability for your actions yeah and
knowing that you did something and then
moving forward and what they're going to
see and and so that's what's been
so interesting because i've been now on
shore i've been over exposed like i've
been overexposed like sometimes it's
like oh my gosh well now it's this show
and then this which turned into
something
huge and those have been
vacation shows yeah they haven't been
shows about you know my real life and
like what i'm doing with my business or
like you know personal life well of
course my personal life but you know
personal life back in charleston yeah or
like you know showing me like you know
in my business and purchasing a home and
things like that it's just been shows
about purely vacation and relationships
and so
that's it's tough to be painted in a
positive light and not that i do myself
any favors right that's fair um but
you know when there's no like okay well
let's now see him like you know going to
work on monday or something right or
like you know figuring out this or doing
this or you know progressing in his life
it's like let's see austin come in like
a tornado and you know you know rip
apart the house for 48 hours and then
leave and then leave right right never
to be heard from everybody from again
right right um so that has been super
interesting but i'll tell you what craig
and i went on tour
um on a podcast tour i know i heard you
guys spoke about me
somebody said april fool's clip craig
believed my april fool's jokes
oh my gosh yes like best prank ever it
was jackie's idea i was sitting on like
on the plane and craig was across the
aisle for me and i was like craig craig
i was like claudia is doing wrong
and and then his like eyes kind of went
wide and he was like
dude it's april fools i was like oh my
gosh i'm such an idiot i'm such a
musician i love that i love that but yes
you went on tour and our very first stop
was dc
and of course we had like a loose kind
of like thing of what we wanted to do
and at first we were like okay so maybe
at this point we'll bring on you know
some fans to play like a you know dating
game they'll bring on fancier and then
do like a q a
and immediately when we walked out right
because it was like a week or so after
the episode had aired and we were like
we you know i don't know what to expect
like we decided to go out you know
together so that no one had any sort of
opportunity to like boo me maybe
right yeah and uh you know but once
again like it's like bravocon like
people are
buying money to come and see you so
they're your fans right not haters to
pay money to come throw tomatoes is
but is me i actually thought the first
you know
show i was like what if tomato gets
thrown at me i like actually not that
thought yeah no of course
but you know what okay so now i guess
the better question is like where do you
stand with lindsay and with sierra okay
um
um so
with lindsay
we uh
spent you know the whole weekend
together right i mean in terms of just
like you know seeing each other and
texting each other and like you know
having chats and you know we're we're as
good as can be our relationship has
certainly um evolved which it should
because now she has carl in her right
you know carlos you know her person and
i couldn't be happier for him could not
be happier for him um
and so so of course it has to change
right it it can't be like you know that
waking up every day and calling each
other it's not healthy yeah we used to
um so
you know we're fine
um sierra is definitely something that
you're going to have to watch on because
what's so interesting is that we've
filmed for winter house
and then they filmed for the summer
house reunion and you can and so it's
just like this series of of events from
how she felt on summer does not match up
to how she's acting on the reunion got
it yes but we said that you can tell
even there seems to be some strife
between paige and lindsay that is like
not they're not even mentioning but it
was extremely tense and nothing that we
saw this season on summer house warrants
that
so you can tell that like there's this
other show that happened in between
because everybody's dynamics have really
changed
i mean
yeah yeah so so
that is so interesting too because there
were things where it was like
uh
you know i don't want to like you know
divulge too too much and but it's like
you know there were things where like
you know the cast was like well our
reunion is is in like you know two weeks
so we're not going to like dive into
this here right kind of thing
the schedule was like a little yeah i
mean there's just so many things going
on plus last night then at the end of
the reunion we got the trailer for
southern charm oh yeah which looks so so
good and what are you
fighting about
i love that [ __ ] song it's so good it
is good
what's this
is that a real fight oh my god no but
but like you know yes and no right so
you know craig and i fight like brothers
it's just like what we do um and at this
point you know we're great but we'll
so we
you are a complicated fellow okay so
we're literally just you know after
dinner drunk and craig and i are like
okay so like craig is like a wrestler
right and i'm more of like a you know
i'm gonna like you know throw you or
something and i was like craig stop it
you know and and and he's tuned up and
i'm like get away from me craig i'm
gonna punch you in the face but like i'm
not gonna punch him in the face because
that's just going over the line and so
then he gets a hold of me and we just go
down and the only language that craig
speaks in that moment is tapping out so
i had to like got it you know i was like
leave me alone it's good okay okay and
then it was a real fight you know have
you ever been on the show before no
right this is your first time on this
show yeah i think yes yes it is okay
because i ask every southern charm
person this question and i will never
not think it's weird and one of my main
takeaways from the reunion i mean from
the trailer
is you know all these people
best friends in charleston dinners and
trips and fights and relationships
and patricia
and i will just like truly never
understand like how more people don't
think it's weird that there's like this
old sophisticated woman like hanging out
with you guys and honestly she was the
main character of the trailer
she was in it more than anyone else
really yes and i think what bothers us
most about her presence even though
these days it's better it's like in the
past and even before your time like
she's really been like on the wrong side
of history about a lot of things with
the cast members and everybody just like
respects and trusts her opinion so much
that it's like i just feel for happiness
it's like the word of god yeah like she
was wrong yeah
but what um like when you guys all go
out to dinner and you're like oh you're
calling like your your mom or something
like yeah hey oh i'm going to dinner at
this like old lady's house like
like to me it just reads so weird you're
like a group of friends who are all of a
certain age and like then you all go to
parties at this woman's house like it's
just it's so weird to me like yeah and
it's never spoken about so that my
question is like what what wait and also
is it because she really is that
presence in all of your lives or is it
because like the bravo universe loves
her being this presence so we're gonna
do more of it okay so i think it's um a
little bit of both okay and and the fact
that she was used as much as she was on
trailer you know does not surprise me at
all in fact like it makes me happy
because people
like to see it you know she wasn't in
like you know the cast photo as she
never is right and so then when she's
not in the cast photo people start to
freak out like oh my god is she not on
the show right and it's like no y'all
rest assured patricia's back no okay
she's always bad you know and and so i
just know what happened right because
you know you ask whitney and he's like
it's a nightmare
and he's like and he's like dude my
mother is on the show you know i'm as
close as they are right you know he's
like dude imagine if your mom was on the
show yeah there's something just like
inherently odd about it i think just
people really love her so they put her
in more and she really she does have
this way about her and she's very iconic
charleston and
does not
so it's like when you go to her home
the last thing that like everyone wants
to be on their p's and q's you know if
if if there's a conversation that she
doesn't want to talk about or have a
part of she's like um excuse me and like
yo she walks away right you know from
you like literally i remember last
sentence i remember you know last season
or two seasons ago whenever naomi was on
it she was like um patricia you know can
we talk and she was like um no darling
you know it kind of like walked away
yeah um no she's definitely an
interesting character but like
you know as a normal person it's like if
me and my friends were all hanging out
and then we like went to a party at some
old lady's house like it would be weird
and she's not some old lady she's like
an iconic south carolinian figure yeah i
mean i guess that i have thought of that
a few times it's weird but like she it
like she embodies exactly what the show
should be about world southern you know
debonair
but it's the same way that like lisa
vanderpump was like always around the
vanderpump rules kids but like there was
it made sense like she was their boss
like there was a connection and
sometimes it just feels like oh we're
going to patricia's house like it just
feels odd yeah yeah i mean look she
she has the old south way about her and
like you know her advice and kind of
like you know you've said and i'm sorry
you know miss patricia but many times
we've talked about it and it's like she
was wrong right about this that this
what she says she goes yeah and then and
then and then she was besties with
catherine right and then now not you
know and it's and and so it's certainly
been an interesting thing where it's
like wait when you took landon under
your wing how did that work out right
thomas on your wing and how did that
work out right that's so true
it's certainly been that way but i mean
she she you know what she's always been
kind and like you know open arms to
generous well
you know she's had some like you know
claps on me yeah right but you know
you'll certainly you know watch and um i
want to switch gears really quickly
because like you literally can't fart
without like it being made into like a
tick tock um i saw like a rumor that
you're dating tasha do you want to clear
that up that's so funny i mean so tasha
and i just did watch what happens live
yes right well not just but but i'm
saying justice recently that is the
extent of it right and so then i see her
out
and shep's girlfriend taylor was like
austin i didn't have stasia behind you
and i was like is it and i was like hey
and and so she had come to meet up with
like our
our crew
and no chase and i are not dating you
think about it she's a great girl oh my
gosh so much fun and you know we had a
blast that day but it was just like
let's take like a pic together because
we did watch what happens live together
yeah that's what i thought but everyone
made a whole thing yeah yeah and and and
you know the views on my you know ig i
was like oh what's good that was like
200 000 views huh okay all right uh what
what the hell just happened um another
southern charm question correct me if
i'm wrong but is madison not in the cast
photo i did not see her is she a cast
member she was on the trailer she she is
on the show she's on the show i have no
idea why she's not in in the poster
that's weird see shep's cousin her name
is marcy she
you know a great girl it also was casted
and she's not in the cast photo so i
don't know i don't know what's going on
there i i i
have no idea but you know you obviously
saw her in the trailer yeah you know
that she's around and she's getting
married she's bought a house yeah or see
i don't know i i know the engagement
thing of course
did you not follow her on instagram no
well she bought a house it's really nice
happy for her
um are you single right now
so
god what what
a simple
question like every simple question it's
like well where do i begin yeah no
seriously but where but but where do i
begin so this whole like a new girl uh
olivia that's on the show um we
definitely our paths are intertwined the
entire time and it's like fresh on the
heels of summer right and so what what i
will say is that you know and not that
she gives a [ __ ] about what happened in
summer but what i'm saying is that in a
sense where i'm like
still kind of like single mode and and
so i'm trying to like figure out this
situation because she's such a wonderful
girl that i'm like how are you so it's
like all
it's all timing yeah it's all timing and
that's what's going to happen it must be
difficult to be on a show where they're
like you know blasting your personal
life from [ __ ] that happened over a year
ago but right now you're living in a
totally different headspace so like
you're you're answering for things that
like you have evolved i don't know him
right
right um
but you know that's that's kind of
always the case right because the show
always takes six
eight months to kind of cut and then to
come out and then you're like and then
it happens right guys it didn't happen
yesterday right a lot of things have
happened since then
um
you know and and part of the reason that
i was so happy to come here today is
because it's like i did want to like you
know talk about those things but then
really like close the chapter on that
and never speak on it yeah again kind of
thing and move forward to
you know the new season of charm that
i'm very excited for and i hope that
everyone else is well i've made peace
with the summer i really have i've
totally like the more we talk about it
the more i'm like what are you doing
like yeah totally yeah
and then that's you know what i thought
no i'm just gonna stop there yeah i
think so like it went well it went well
just end it um last question for you
how's your tripod business going oh my
gosh so that is certainly uh showcased
on the show good um i'm very excited and
obviously i feel blessed that i have
like in the platform that i do to to be
able to show that and so what i did was
in a nutshell i moved production where
it was in the upstate of south carolina
so about three hours away now it's in
downtown charleston so so i got to go
there and film a bunch i come out with a
couple of new beers
and we kind of show the journey
um
which i think that a lot of people you
know i like
over the years have have seen and know
that
once you try to dive into like the meat
and potatoes of it you know some people
are like
boring it's a little boring yeah right
of course so it's like trying to like
hit the highlights and it's like you
know new beers and like a new like in a
production facility and let's go here on
like a guy's trip and see this oh that's
funny for this and and um so you'll
definitely see um some chop up stuff and
it's doing wonderfully so now since
production's near you when people come
to charleston can they like do a tasting
a brewery like a brewery excursion
that's like great for the
tourists and fans yep so i use another
brewery to bring my beer and it's called
um palmetto brewing company and so they
have all all my beer on top and and
that's where they brew it and so that is
like ground zero right if you come to
charleston and it's right downtown
and then you can go to craig's store are
they close to each other i've never been
yeah to charleston you should come to
i've been watching i know i've heard i
would love it you should certainly come
to charleston everyone should come to
charleston but um
and everyone does come to charleston
especially from new york city it is like
it it was a mass exodus down there but
you know it's it's like a mile away okay
and like a charleston mile is different
than a new york mile yes okay so it's
like it's not traffic they're like 15
minutes not like you know 30 minutes in
a car totally yeah um well thank you for
being vulnerable and honest with us we
really appreciate your canada we
appreciate you being here everyone if
you want to keep up with austin follow
me on instagram oh also we were talking
about you before you got here when are
you gonna change your instagram username
claudia doesn't like it you don't like
no no it's like you're like i get it
when you were like i know a commoner
like you're a celebrity now and like i'm
trying to find your instagram and i'm
like where the [ __ ] is awesome oh my
gosh that's funny actually i never
thought about that um
and you know who hates it too is spencer
pratt he always tells me he's right he's
like he's like dude just make it at
austin kroll right you're building a
business you're brand building you know
what i kind of like it because it's like
you're still that same guy you haven't
the theme hasn't changed that's true i i
just thought it was funny like matthew
mcconaughey's you know weiner i mean
right what oh it's from ten ten ten
things i hate about no wait no this
wait what's the reference when she names
his penis
she names uh yeah princess sofia yeah
and then he's like
what about something manly like cruel
the warrior king oh you know what
that i do love a pop culture reference
that's why and so a girlfriend of mine
back right before the show began was
like i'm going to change mine if you
change yours to this and so we both kind
of change it together and i've never
changed it since i like that me too
after hearing the explanation um
i don't hate it as much okay i don't but
you know maybe i should right because
because if you don't get the reference
then it makes no sense no it sounds like
you're calling yourself a warrior i know
it just sounds like an inside joke from
like before you're famous right like you
really like it oh my god that's funny
yeah so so you're a podcaster now
pillows and beers right with craig
everyone can catch up with you on the
air follow crawl the warrior king on
instagram yeah that eye roll and thank
you so much for being here austin we
really appreciate your presence guys
thank you so much and thank you guys for
listening hope you have an amazing day
and we'll see you tomorrow bye
you